listen we all wear them we're all sick
of them of course we're talking about
mass so what are we going to do this
morning we're going to take a close look
at which masks offer the best protection
against
covid the cdc recommends those layered
masks like the n95 and notes that a snug
fit is very crucial but with so many
masks on the market it can be very very
confusing we asked people in los angeles
what do they look for in a good mask
the most important thing i look for when
i'm picking a mask is the
amount of protection that it's going to
give i think
anything can be a mask long is just
covering your mouth and your nose i
prefer to wear a surgical mask
they're
disposable i don't have to worry about
washing them so often preferably
surgical masks because i feel like
they're a lot more safer
and they say and more
reliable i don't really care about
design as long as it's comfortable to
wear for the whole day out in public i
prefer to wear a cloth mask or
disposable mask because they're easy to
just
make sure that they're clean i look for
it to be comfortable and i look for the
mask
to cover my face accordingly and let me
breathe correctly it must have
comfortable straps yeah i'm not gonna
pick a mask based on you know
how cool it looks or how cute it looks
you know it's not it's not a fashion
statement it's a health statement
very good point sir cue aaron collins a
self-described mass nerd he is an
aerosol scientist so on his youtube
channel colin's test mask in his home
laboratory and rates their ability to
filter out the aerosols erin collins
we're happy to say joins us this morning
good to see you aaron collins i love
your story you just started doing this
on your own and you got a lot of pick up
on your youtube channel because you
certainly seem to know what you're
talking about so take us through what
are you looking for and what makes a
good mask
yeah i think the most important aspects
of a mass are kind of three things and a
lot of those people in l.a hit on it
it's about filtration it's about fit and
it's about comfort and so what we talk
about when we talk about masks is we
want to see all three of those things so
some people have talked about the
surgical mask so that features the
filtration and has that melt-blown layer
so it has that good technology that we
have but the promised surgical mask they
kind of lack the fit and so there's
other mass designs like kn 95s that
feature that fit or kf-94s that also
feature fit and of course the n95 we're
all familiar with that this is a cup
style also features that good tight fit
so it's not true you heard one guy say
look as long as it covers your nose in
your mouth you're okay that's certainly
not the truth
it's certainly not the best mask but i
will always say that the the mask you're
wearing is better than no mask at all so
at least they're on the first part of
that
so aaron uh you mentioned kn95
n95 surgical those are types of masks
but are there brands that people can
sort through and which do you like
yeah so you know in kn 95 that's the
chinese mass test standard so i'm a big
fan of the powcom bnf or the palcom
excuse me here kn95 but there's also
like us made kn-95s which is a little
weird because of our regulatory system
like bnx they're really cool there's
tons of great n95 options out there i'm
a big fan of the 3m aura series you can
get these at home depot the 9205 plus
this is a great mask great protection
good fit it's very comfortable to wear
um and then there's also the kf-94 and
the kf-94 is the south korean standard
it's their general population mass
standard they designed it for like what
would you have to do if you had a
pandemic and you needed to mask everyone
they were kind of ahead of us in some
ways uh that's what looks like oh go
ahead oh no it'll continue
oh i was gonna say so the kf94 it
features this kind of cool boat shape uh
and again the difference between you
know kn 95s and n95s are these feature
in ear loops uh like these kf94 and k95
and n95 is always going to feature
headbands so that's a good easy way to
know what are the differences between
those masks
erin i was just going to reassure any of
our viewers at home who are feverishly
trying to write down these names which
are not familiar that i'm confident we
will put them on our website and i do
also wonder how do people know that what
they're buying online is a genuine
article not a counterfeit
that's a great question so in general uh
in the in 95 space if you purchase from
big box retailers or direct from the
manufacturer you want to go to amazon
just make sure it's shipped by and sold
by the the direct supplier so if it's
shipping sold by amazon in the case of
3m you're going to get a 3m mask the k
in 95 space is a little bit tougher so
what i recommend is looking for the
labeling requirements so the kn-95
standard requires you to label both the
manufacturer the standard it's tested
against a bunch of numbers because you
know as engineers it says gb
2626-2019 and it should also label kn95
on there so you want to see all three of
those things on the mask that's a good
indication that they're at least
following the labeling standards
all right aaron collins i'm looking at
my kn95 here it does in fact have the gb
2626 so well done to my wife katie tur
you ordered some legitimate items i
appreciate that uh we appreciate you
walking through us all walking through
all this as i said the details will be
on our website uh erin collins thank you
very much
my pleasure thank you for having me